[Musik]
die Welt wandelt sich von einer vom
Westen dominierten hin zu einer
multipolaren Weltordnung mit China und
Indien als neuen Machtzentren wird
dieser Übergang friedlich verlaufen oder
müssen wir mit kriegen und
handelskriegen rechnen wie stabil ist
diese neue Welt und kann Deutschland
darin vielleicht sogar eine
vorbild-rolle übernehmen wie es mein
Gast der indische Schriftsteller
Kulturhistoriker und internationale
Bestsellerautor pankay misra vorschlägt
[Musik]
Herr sie haben unlängst im Spiegel
geschrieben Deutschland würde nach
Westen Schlafwandeln wie haben sie das
gemeint
weil als sie
gefühlt
dann erscheint einem Deutschland wie ein
Land das geographisch eindeutig zum
Westen gehört ein Teil im Westen ist
aber sich doch auch irgendwie wegen
seiner Geschichte und wegen seiner
anders gearteten Entwicklung als Land
vom Westen abhängt
in Deutschland
betrachtet man
wie es gerne genannt wird den langen Weg
nach Westen als ein positiven Weg als
ein endlich ankommen in der richtigen
Wertegemeinschaft in dem Essay im
Spiegel klang das so als hätten sie
daran zweifeln
kommen auf wenn man sich anschaut was
derzeit geschieht
selbstverständlich war die Aufnahme
Deutschlands in die westliche
Gemeinschaft der Demokratien ein äußerst
positiver Schritt
die Stelle aber jetzt bewusst in Frage
ob dieser Weg für Deutschland weiterhin
gangbar ist jetzt wo der Westen selbst
ein in sich nicht mehr ganz so stimmiges
Gebilde geworden ist
sie beschreiben auch in den letzten Buch
das hingeschrieben haben die Geschichte
des Westens als eine
aufstiegsgeschichte aber auch inzwischen
als eine Verfallsgeschichte das ist ja
eine ziemlich starke these zu sagen der
Westen verfällt können Sie erklären was
sie damit meinen dass der Westen
verfällt
relativen Sinn
über 200 Jahre lang haben einige Länder
des Westens vor allem die USA
Großbritannien und Frankreich
verschiedene Teile der Welt in Besitz
gehalten
dabei bauten sie sich starke
Volkswirtschaften auf denn sie
herrschten über die Ressourcen über
Rohstoffe
und sie hatten Zugriff auf billige
Arbeitskräfte oft mit moralisch
verwerflichen Methoden wie etwa die
Sklavenhaltung
dieses Zeitalter die Welt des weißen
Mannes ist vorbei
als weißer Mann in Afrika oder Asien war
mein Herr und Meister über alles was
einem Unterstand diese Epoche ist
beendet wir sprechen hier also von einer
Schwächung des Westens die in der Zeit
der entkolonisierung um die Mitte des 20
Jahrhunderts einsetzte als Nationen wie
Indien China Indonesien sich von den
europäischen Herrschern loszulösen be
und sich politisch geistig und moralisch
einen Platz auf der größeren
weltgeschichtlichen Bühne verschafften
das meine ich wenn wir von einem Verfall
sprechen
so that's speaking off wenn wir speaking
of the client Orbis Leben verständlich
bleiben die USA ein sehr mächtiges Land
auch heute noch sie zeigen die größte
Militärpräsenz weltweit sie besitzen ein
riesiges Atomwaffenarsenal und sie sind
eine sehr starke Volkswirtschaft aber im
Vergleich zu dem wie sie vor 50 oder 60
Jahren da standen entwickeln sie sich
jetzt zurück China dagegen arbeitet an
seinem Aufstieg es tritt geopolitisch
und wirtschaftlich viel selbstbewusster
auf kurz gesagt wir müssen schlicht zur
Kenntnis nehmen dass der Westen nicht
mehr das mächtige Gebilde darstellt dass
er früher einmal war jetzt hat der
Begriff die kleinen Niedergang ja wie
sie gerade selber gesagt haben
verschiedene Bedeutungen
also auf der einen Seite kann man sagen
okay die relative Bedeutung der Ökonomie
der westlichen Staaten nimmt ab das
heißt also früher waren wir völlig
dominant über die gesamte Welt
inzwischen sind ist mit China ein
mächtiger Konkurrent entstanden
möglicherweise ja auch mit Indien
vielleicht irgendwann mit Brasilien oder
dem Iran oder afrikanische Länder die
dazu kommen könnten also sozusagen ein
ökonomischer Niedergang in Relation zu
den anderen das ist noch einfach
nachzuvollziehen aber sie haben auch
gerade gesagt es gibt auch einen
moralischen Vorfall des Westens da
können Sie sich vorstellen das sehen
viele Menschen im Westen sicher ganz
anders das müssen sie begründen
sicher würden sie das anders sehen und
wenn wir bestimmte Werte wie Demokratie
oder Rechtsstaatlichkeit nehmen so
werden diese Werte sicherlich in großen
Teilen des Westens weiterhin hoch
gehalten ich würde trinken aber wenn man
sich das kulturelle Prestige die
moralische Wertschätzung anschaut die
Ländern wie den USA und England früher
entgegengebracht wurden wer könnte dann
heute noch behaupten dass nach Donald
Trump nach Boris Johnson nach all dem
was in den letzten 10 Jahren dort
geschehen ist diese Länder immer noch
weltweit in demselben hohen Ansehen
stünden oder dass sie in Asien und
Afrika immer noch Gehör finden wenn sie
von Demokratie oder vom Kampf gegen die
Autokratien sprechen gegen Russland und
China
immer weniger Menschen wollen diese
Botschaften ernst nehmen im Gegenteil
das alles wird heute zunehmend in Frage
gestellt also sprechen wir gerade von
einem relativen Niedergang so haben
insbesondere die USA Jen Hüfte
Überzeugungskraft verloren die sie einst
besaßen als sie noch als Leuchtturm der
Demokratie als demokratisches Vorbild
galten
wir haben doch die vielen inneren
Probleme der Vereinigten Staaten gesehen
zu viele als das die USA weiterhin ein
überzeugendes Vorbild für die Demokratie
oder überhaupt für demokratische Werte
sein können
Demokratie in gentle was ist aus ihrer
Sicht die Erklärung dafür dass die
selbstprognose die führende Denker des
Westens nach Ende des Kalten Krieges
aufgestellt haben Francis Fukuyama der
hier auch schon als Gast war z.B dass
wir in einen Zeitalter liberaler
Demokratien auf der ganzen Welt
irgendwann oder sogar zeitnah kommen
würden das Ende der Geschichte erreicht
wäre sich die Werte des Westens
durchgesetzt hätten das ist dazu nicht
gekommen ist dass wir also heute eher
sowas haben wie eine Renaissance
autokratische Systeme das nicht
demokratische Länder
zunehmend ein ökonomischer und damit
auch ein politischer Macht zunehmen was
glauben sie ist der Grund warum es zu
dieser Entwicklung gekommen ist
das ist eben so wenn man in solchen
Fantasien schwelgt wenn man sich diesem
Tagtraum hingibt das eines Tages alle
Länder den westlichen führungsmächten
gleichen würden dass sie alle die
freiheitliche Demokratie einführen
müssten weil es ja keine Alternative
gäbe zu diesem vorbestimmten Endziel der
Geschichte ein Mann der Versuchung
nachgibt das zu glauben
viele glauben es ja damals 1989 und noch
weiter darüber hinaus und viele hängen
bis zum heutigen Tag diesem Glauben an
aber
ernst nimmt was die Geschichte der
modernen Welt uns lehrt dann müssen wir
zugeben es ist unfassbar schwer den
Prozess der wirtschaftlichen
Modernisierung und der
Industrialisierung zu durchlaufen und
gleichzeitig eine Demokratie zu bleiben
oder eine solche zu werden
man muss erkennen dass die beiden
Prozesse von Natur aus miteinander im
Widerstreit liegen das haben wir immer
wieder und in vielen Ländern erkennen
müssen zum Beispiel gerade hier in
Deutschland oder in Japan wie schwer es
für diese Länder war demokratische
Prozesse mit dem überlebensnotwendigen
Gebot der Modernisierung auf dem Weg zu
starken Nationalstaaten in Einklang zu
bringen
und genau diese Geschichte wiederholt
sich jetzt überall in Asien Afrika und
Lateinamerika
diese Grundeinsichten aus der jüngeren
Geschichte gilt es zu verstehen
wenn man aber noch immer Fantasie
Gebilde darüber aufbaut wie die Welt
nach dem Ebenbild Amerikas neu
geschaffen werden soll dann ist das das
Problem derer die so denken
leider funktioniert die Welt einfach
nicht so und sie hat auch in der
Vergangenheit nicht so funktioniert
was wir heute erkennen müssen ist die
Notwendigkeit uns von diesen
amerikanisch dominierten westlichen
Fantasien los zu sagen nach denen früher
einmal die Welt sicherte ändern sollen
dieser American fantasies stattdessen
kommt es darauf an wie Welt zu
betrachten und zu analysieren wie sie
heute ist
wenn sie davon sprechen dass wir aus
diesem Fantasien oder aus diesem
narrativ wie man heute sagen würde
ausbrechen müssen
dass die ganze Welt irgendwann eine
liberale
Demokratie sein wird nach westlichen
Muster
sondern dass jedes Land seinen eigenen
Entwicklungsweg geht und gar nicht
vorher bestimmt ist wo dieser
Entwicklungsweg am Ende mal enden wird
dann bedeutet das natürlich was also wir
stehen dann ja vor der Situation wenn
unsere Leid Erzählung Weg ist uns neu
besinnen zu müssen und wir müssen ja
eine neue Erzählung finden also wenn es
tatsächlich nicht so kommt wie Fukuyama
prognostiziert hat und wie sicher zu
recht sagen sehr viele Leute eigentlich
bis heute glauben wollen dann müsste man
das durch eine andere Erzählung ersetzen
hätten sie einen Vorschlag wie dieses
narrativ für eine multipolare
Weltordnung aussehen soll
etwas ganz Wesentliches angesprochen
nämlich dass das Zeitalter der großen
Erzählungen vorüber ist
was war diese große Erzählung in den
letzten 30 Jahren im Wesentlichen
lautete sie
Globalisierung ist gleich
Amerikanisierung
Globalisierung unter amerikanischen
Vorzeichen die Volkswirtschaften müssen
freie Marktwirtschaften werden
Sozialismus kam nicht in Frage
Planwirtschaft gar nicht in Frage wir
sollten letztlich genauso konsumieren
wie eine Minderheit von Europäern und
die Amerikaner
alles auf demokratische Strukturen
hinaus das ganze war eben mein
Fantasiegebilde und das ist im
Wesentlichen zerplatzt
einer der Gründe weshalb wir das
Aufblühen von ethnisch rassistischen
Heilslehren oder von radikalen
Ideologien in Ländern wie China Indien
oder Russland finden ist dass dort
herrschenden Eliten aber auch die Bürger
die das ganze Gerede von
amerikanisierung und Globalisierung
glaubten inzwischen von diesem Glauben
abgefallen sind
so erzeugen sie nun ihre eigenen
narrative um diese zerfallenen
Meistererzählungen zu ersetzen der
Hindu-Nationalismus der russische
Imperialismus der chinesische
überlegenheitsglaube all das sind
Versuche die letzte weltumspannende
Ideologie zu ersetzen die eben in
Amerikanisierung plus Globalisierung
bestand das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt
wenn wir heute über entamerikanisierung
sprechen dann hört man viel von einem
Bedeutungsverlust des Dollars die Leute
entdolarisieren sich verwenden andere
Zahlungsverfahren
die amerikanische Hegemonie wird
abgeschüttelt aber die wichtigste
Veränderung vollzieht sich tatsächlich
im Bewusstsein
ich glaube sehr viele Menschen haben
sich schon vom amerikan deutschen Modell
verabschiedet sie glauben dass es
versagt hat ja sogar in Amerika selbst
gescheitert ist das erklärt auch den
Aufstieg von Leuten wie Donald Trump und
den Klammergriff den der trumpismus
heute in der amerikanischen Politik
ausübt die Leute erkennen hey das ist ja
nicht das was wir eigentlich wollen wir
wollen doch kein gescheitertes Vorbild
nachahmen ein Vorbild das in Amerika
selbst schief gelaufen ist also müssen
wir einen Ersatz dafür schaffen würden
Sie denn wenn sie sagen dass Master nach
aktiv ja die große amerikanische
Erzählung hat Konkurrenz bekommen ja
bröckelt verliert an Bedeutung würden
sie diese Konkurrenz unter moralischen
Gesichtspunkt als gleichwertig
betrachten sie haben gesagt neben das
große amerikanische narrativ ist der
russische Imperialismus
überlegenheitsfantasien in Indien in
China getreten würden Sie sagen dass es
alles irgendwie
gleich oder würden Sie sagen das muss
man alles sehr unterschiedlich moralisch
betrachten und es ist auch wichtig das
zu bewerten
Problem ist wenn man etwas moralisch
bewertet dann muss man ganz klar sagen
wo man in der Welt steht
wenn man in China lebt und den Aufstieg
nach einem Jahrhundert des Bürgerkriegs
und der Dominierung durch fremde
Herrscher erlebt hat dann wird man wohl
zu dem Schluss kommen dass die Bilanz
insgesamt positiv ist das China endlich
an souveräner startet seinen Platz in
der Welt behaupten kann und von anderen
Ländern ernst genommen und mit Würde
behandelt wird selbst wenn das
politische System durch Autoritarismus
geprägt ist
dass sie endlich die Achtung anderer
Nationen erleben man kann ruhig das
chinesische oder indische System
moralisch bewerten das steht jedem frei
das kann ich gerade auch als
Schriftsteller machen
ich kann selbstverständlich nur in einer
demokratischen Gesellschaft arbeiten und
würden in einer chinesischen Mannschaft
könnte ich nicht
meine Entscheidungen sind im Grunde
durch meinen Wohnort und durch meine
Berufswahl getroffen aber wir müssen
auch die Meinungen und Wünsche der Leute
berücksichtigen die in den genannten
Ländern leben ihre Weltsicht ihre
Selbstbilder müssen wir betrachten
es reicht nicht aus irgendwo in Berlin
oder New York oder London zu sitzen und
moralische Urteile zu predigen
living else aber mein Eindruck ist
eigentlich dass die Moral in der
außenpolitischen internationalen Politik
massiv zunimmt in Deutschland sprechen
wir von einer Werte geleiteten
Außenpolitik das heißt wir erleben
eigentlich gegenüber einem ökonomischen
Pragmatismus den wir in Deutschland
lange praktiziert haben über Jahrzehnte
hinweg
haben wir uns verabschiedet und wir
gehen sehr viel stärker rein dass wir
sagen mit den Ländern handeln wir nicht
mehr und da werden Frauenrechte
missachtet und das sind Autokratien das
heißt also Werte spielen heute in der
Außenpolitik eine sehr viel größere
Rolle
finden Sie das grundsätzlich richtig
oder halten Sie das für falsch und
würden sie wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
sagen die unsicherer der Westen sich
seine eigenen Werte wird umso wichtiger
werden die Werte in der Außenpolitik
eine Methode wie man Machtansprüche
behaupten kann wenn einem die
wirtschaftliche oder militärische Macht
aus den Händen gleitet besteht darin
dass man nachweist wie überlegen man
doch immer noch ist
leider wird man damit umso
heuchlerischer und unglaubwürdiger in
den Augen der Weltbevölkerung da stehen
[Musik]
wegen seiner Gastgeberrolle für die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft kritisieren
oder andere Länder wegen der
Menschenrechtsverletzungen tadeln der
Rest der Welt weiß Bescheid
denn er ist dank der digitalen
Kommunikation bestens im Bilde darüber
dass nämlich deutschland und andere
westliche Länder mit eben diesen
kritisierten Staaten Handeltreiben
werden Waffen verkauft und nach Saudi
Arabien die ganze retourik überzeugt die
Menschen schlichtweg nicht mehr zumal
die Leute heutzutage viel stärker
politisiert und auch viel zynischer
geworden sind
die moralisierende Rhetorik nützt meist
nur den hier lebenden Menschen oder der
Eitelkeit der Menschen die in Moral
gesättigten reden schwelgen aber das ist
letztlich vollkommen wirkungslos
jetzt machen sie ein Vorschlag in dem
sie sagen die Zukunft Deutschlands lege
darin mehr Verantwortung zu übernehmen
das ist eine ungewöhnliche Formulierung
weil wenn wir in Deutschland von mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen sprechen meinen
wir immer mehr militärisches Engagement
mehr Waffenlieferungen wer Präsenz der
Bundeswehr und so weiter sie meinen
etwas anderes sie meinen mit mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen sich stärker
aus dem amerikanischen Master narrativ
und diesen Verflechtungen zu lösen und
stolz darauf zu sein was Deutschland
geschafft hat was andere westliche
Länder nicht geschafft haben können Sie
das erklären
ich bin ja in Indien aufgewachsen und
habe mich dort schon mit deutscher
Geschichte und deutscher Literatur
beschäftigt
mir wurde klar dass Deutschland einen
Sonderfall in der Welt des Westens
darstellt und in seiner Geschichte und
mit seiner Reaktion auf die französische
Aufklärung auf die Französische
Revolution neuartige Wege beschritten
hat
die Deutschland in die Nähe viele andere
Länder in Asien und Afrika rückt die
sich ebenfalls mit Verspätungen
modernisiert haben
Afrika
was kann man nun daraus lernen ist
Deutschland wirklich ein Mitglied der
westlichen Staatengemeinschaft kann sich
ja ja seit 1945 aber sogar noch nach
1945 ist es so dass Deutschland sich vom
Vorbild des Westens etwa dem der
Vereinigten Staaten Englands und
Frankreichs absetzt
das sind ja die dominierenden
imperialistischen Mächte des 19 und 20
Jahrhunderts die haben sich im Gegensatz
zu Deutschland nie vollständig mit ihrer
Vergangenheit auseinandergesetzt mit
einer Vergangenheit die im Wesentlichen
durch Gewalt und die Ausplünderung
schwächerer Völker manchmal durch
Genozid dann indigenen Bevölkerungen
geprägt war auch durch Sklaverei durch
hurrende Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit die niemals voll
anerkannt und bewältigt worden sind
und wenn dann versuche der echten
Auseinandersetzung mit diesen Verbrechen
z.B in den Vereinigten Staaten
unternommen werden dann sieht man ja
jetzt einen massiven Gegenschlag der
Republikaner gegen die Aufklärung über
rassistische Ungerechtigkeit
der Vereinigten Staaten werden könnte
sogar eine Kampagne gegen den
Schulunterricht zum Thema Rassismus
vergleichen Sie das mit dem deutschen
Modell wo all diese Themen schon vor
langer Zeit eingeführt worden sind und
mittlerweile mehrere Generationen
umfassen die über die in der deutschen
Vergangenheit begangenen Verbrechen
aufgeklärt wurden
so dieser so besondere Prozess diese
ganz besondere geschichtliche Erfahrung
versetzt Deutschland erneut in eine
eigenständige Position
ich bin wie so viele andere immer wieder
hoch erstaunt warum Deutschland so
beharrlich an der Seite dieser
imperialistischen Mächte des Westens
steht jedoch in großen Teilen des
globalen Südens zunehmend an
Glaubwürdigkeit einbüßen
lassen
warum kann Deutschland aus einer eigenen
Erfahrung keine Tugend machen und sich
selbst als unabhängige souveräne Nation
mit einer besonderen Geschichte
darstellen
und warum kann es seine so besondere
historische und wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung eben nicht als etwas durch
den Nationalsozialismus geprägtes
darstellen sondern als geprägt durch den
Sozialstaat durch einen Staat der auf
die Belange seiner Bürger eingeht und
sie ernst nimmt
Deutschland steht doch bekanntermaßen
für den modernen Sozialstaat die meisten
Menschen im globalen Süden wissen nicht
sehr viel darüber
die Briten präsentieren sich ja gerne
als diejenigen die den Gedanken der
freien Marktwirtschaft des freien
Handels in die Welt gebracht und wie
viel Wohlstand sie damit in die übrige
Welt gesetzt hätten Deutschland dagegen
erhebt für sich selbst nie solche
geistesgeschichtlichen Ansprüche
ich finde das schon höchster erstaunlich
wie es immer noch in einer Art
Verteidigungsstellung verharrt
ich würde zwei Punkte dazu sagen also
erstens ist der Grund warum die
Deutschen ihre Geschichte sehr viel
besser aufgearbeitet haben ihre Schauer
und verbrechensgeschichte die die größte
war die wahrscheinlich hier ein Volk auf
diesem Planeten angerichtet hat im
Gegensatz zu den Verbrechens Geschichten
anderer westlicher Länder liegt daran
dass wir den Zweiten Weltkrieg verloren
haben
Sieger hinterfragen ihre Geschichte
nicht Verlierer sind gezwungen ihre
Geschichte zu hinterfragen deswegen
hatten wir natürlich eine andere
Ausgangsposition was den zweiten Teil
anbelangt warum Deutschland nicht in auf
den größeren Abstand geht zu den Ländern
des Westens ihre Geschichte nicht
entsprechend aufgearbeitet haben und die
sie imperialistische Mächte nennen ich
meine wenn wir angesichts des Ukraine
Krieges vor einer Situation stehen an
diesen Krieg empfinden wir als einen
Krieg gegen den Westen dann ist das
naheliegendste dass man zusammen steht
außerdem wenn Deutschland hingehen würde
und eine eigene Rolle spielen würde dann
würde es Europa verlassen ich meine wie
viel Jahrzehnte Mühen und Anstrengungen
haben wir ja da reingelegt ein
gemeinsames Europa zu werden das nicht
für ein Mitglied Europas einen Sonderweg
oder eine andere Rolle vorsieht das
wären zumindestens ziemlich klare
Erklärungen warum Deutschland in dieser
Situation in der wir uns heute befinden
die Kluft zu Amerika nicht vergrößert
sondern sie erschließt
dem ist sicherlich so aber ich füge
gleich noch an es ist wahrscheinlich
wichtiger sich die Geschichte aus der
verlierersicht statt aus der
gewinnersicht anzuschauen
wenn man Geschichte aus der Perspektive
der Sieger betrachtet wird man sich
täuschen lassen und das mag wohl auch
die genannten Theorien über das Ende der
Geschichte erklären
die kommen ja aus der Sicht der Sieger
und das führt letztlich zu fast
wahnhaften Fantasien
die Geschichte aus Verlierer Sicht
betrachtet kommt man zu einem
pragmatischeren Verständnis unserer
Geschichte und nicht nur der Geschichte
sondern auch der Gegenwart und der
Zukunft
ohne anderen oder sich selbst Sand in
die Augen zu streuen das ist sehr
wichtig einer der Gründe weshalb
Deutschland seine besondere Geschichte
immer wieder hervorheben sollte ist dass
es eine Verlierer Geschichte ist und die
Welt ist ja voll von Verlierer Ländern
100 Jahren die Verlierer Straße
beschritten sie alle versuchen nun zu
den Siegern der Geschichte
aufzuschließen Deutschland hat das nach
langem Ringen geschafft aber das
bedeutet nicht dass es seine vergangene
Verlierer Position vergessen sollte denn
das bleibt für die große Mehrheit der
Weltbevölkerung von herausragender
Bedeutung
was ich jetzt vorschlage mag utopisch
klingen aber ich möchte doch anregen
dass wir nicht einfach an der Seite
eines vorübergehend geeinten Westens
stehen sollten und ich hebe hervor
vorübergehend geeint
wir haben doch kurz vor Ausbruch des
ukrainekrieges die Möglichkeit eines
Bürgerkrieges in den Vereinigten Staaten
diskutiert damals haben wir doch und mit
wir meine ich die Europäer darüber
beraten ob man Sanktionen gegen ein Land
verhängen sollte das jetzt dann
vorderste Front im ukrainekrieg steht
nämlich Polen das wegen zunehmend
freiheitsbeschränkender Demokratie
feindlicher Bestrebungen in die Kritik
geraten war
zusammen bekannt ist auch der Fall
Ungarn eine Demokratie die in Schieflage
geraten ist und es gibt weitere
Beispiele die einem da einfallen
sie steht auf der Kippe
möglicherweise bleibt sie nicht bestehen
wenn wir weiter in die Zukunft schauen
falls dieser Krieg sich in die Länge
zieht
ich glaube die Frage bleibt offen welche
Rolle Deutschland daran spielen will
China und Russland stehen auf einer
Seite viele Länder des globalen Südens
sagen wir wollen hier nicht parteier
greifen das ist eine europäischer Krieg
oder vielleicht auch einen Krieg des
Westens der uns nicht betrifft
das Donuts eine hochgradig instabile
Lage zu sein so gerechtfertigt doch
Deutschlands frühere Partei Name gewesen
ist glaube ich doch dass die Deutschen
ihre Position überdenken sollten das
Land kann sich nicht einfach an dieser
Position festklammern denn derzeit
befinden wir uns in einem Park ob die
Sanktionen funktionieren ist noch nicht
klar bisher funktionieren sie ja nicht
denn große Teile der Welt wollen sich
daran nicht beteiligen sie sitzen den
Handel mit Russland fort haben ihn sogar
noch ausgebaut
putin ist es also leider gelungen den
schlimmsten möglichen Schaden der
Sanktionen abzuwenden
wenn Sie diese Ansicht vertreten dass
dieses Europa ja ohnehin viel fragiler
ist als wir das gerne für uns
beschreiben und daran erinnern welche
Probleme wir mit Ungarn mit Polen und so
weiter gehabt haben und das ist ja
vielleicht nur deswegen im Augenblick so
geschlossen ist weil es gegen einen
gemeinsamen Feind geht das aber keine
konsistente Geschlossenheit in Europa
vorliegt
die Vorstellung dass das Deutschland das
lange nicht nur der Motor war sondern
man kann sagen in den Zeiten von Helmut
Kohl ja war Deutschland nicht nur die
die Lokomotive die da reingefahren ist
sondern hat eine Lokomotive die den
ganzen Bahnhof gezogen hat ja also
Deutschland ist eine riesige Rolle
gespielt bei der Einigung Europas dann
kann es sich ja nicht aus diesem Europa
in irgendeiner Form weg oder raus
bewegen also mir ist praktisch oder
pragmatisch gar nicht klar wie das
aussehen sollte und das gleiche ist die
Westbindung ist einmal einerseits
historisch nach 45 Marshallplan
Wiederaufbau Deutschlands historische
Dankbarkeit sehr stark und sie ist jetzt
gerade in dem Bild dass die Demokratie
in ihre Werte gegen aufstrebende
Autokratien verteidigen müssen oder
kriegsführende Autokratien wie Russland
sozusagen das naheliegendste überhaupt
wie würden Sie denn wenn Sie Ihre
Meinung vertreten als Politiker klar
machen wollen dass in einer solchen
historischen Situation Deutschland
stärker weg muss von den USA und auch
quasi in Europa eine eigene Position
formulieren das ist in alledem was sie
sagen genau gegen den augenblicklichen
Zeitgeist argumentiert das ist ihm doch
sicher bewusst
ich bin mir dessen durchaus bewusst ich
wiederhole noch einmal dass es ein
utopischer Vorschlag ist denn die
gegenwärtigen Umstände die sie sehr
eloquent beschreiben verhindern ist dass
Deutschland tatsächlich diesen Weg
einschlägt
man sollte ihn aber als Möglichkeit
aufrechterhalten nicht als
Handlungsoptionen die sofort ergriffen
werden könnte
denn es ist vorstellbar dass sich der
Zeitgeist ändert dass etwa einen
republikanischer Präsident in den
Vereinigten Staaten an die Macht kommt
innerhalb der republikanischen Partei
gibt es auch bereits Isolationisten die
sagen warum geben wir so viel Geld aus
warum schenken wir der Ukraine so viel
Geld das wird doch bloß von korrupten
Eliten vergeudet wir müssen uns
zurückziehen das ist nicht unser
Kriegs wenn ein solcher Präsident in den
Vereinigten Staaten an die Macht kommt
wird Deutschland geradezu gezwungen sein
seine Position neu zu justieren oder
etwa nicht was ich damit sagen will ist
dass diese Situation die wir jetzt haben
nicht stillsteht nicht ewig ist sie
könnte sich ändern und wir alle müssen
uns auf diese Veränderungen Vorbereiten
der Krieg könnte eine unvorhersehbare
Wendung nehmen wir müssen uns also schon
jetzt auf eine ganze Reihe von denkbaren
Verläufen gefasst machen
was ist wenn ein republikanischer
Präsident an die Macht kommt oder wenn
kein republikanischer Präsident an die
Macht kommt der derzeitige Präsident die
derzeitige Regierung oder ein
demokratischer Präsident Steuern stärker
auf eine Konfrontation mit China zu ist
Deutschland bereit das im Rahmen eines
westlichen Bündnisses gegen Autokratie
mitzumachen trägt Deutschland das alles
ungesehen mit ist es voll Mitglied im
Verein der Demokratien gegen Autokratien
ist es bereit als Teil der NATO in einen
Krieg gegen China zu ziehen
ich glaube diese Fragen verlangen
irgendwann eine Antwort wenn die
Konfrontation mit China stärker wird und
alles deutet der darauf hin dass sie
sich verschaffen wird
[Musik]
wenn wir darüber reden würden sie
sprechen davon Deutschland isoliert als
Deutschland also aus deutscher
Perspektive könnte man immer noch sagen
das ist vielleicht ein Weg den wir nicht
bis zum Ende mitgehen würden allein
aufgrund unserer enormen
wirtschaftlichen Verflechtungen mit
China ich glaube das könnten wir bei
Strafe unseres Untergangs gar nicht
überlegen lange bevor wir über die Moral
eines solchen Krieges nachdenken würden
wir das nicht machen aber wir sind eben
Teil eines Europa indem wir ja mit den
von ihnen Verurteilten imperialistischen
Mächten das Frankreich des 19
Jahrhunderts das England des 19
Jahrhunderts gemeinsam versuchen etwas
zu kriegen und auch zu diesem Europa
geht es bei Strafe des wirtschaftlichen
Untergangs für Deutschland keine
Alternative deswegen ist mir nicht
richtig klar wie kann Deutschland auf
der einen Seite fest integriert in
Europa bleiben und andererseits eine
Distanz aufbauen zu Interessen die
vielleicht am Ende nicht seine eigenen
sind wie wie muss ich mir das
pragmatisch vorstellen
habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Antworten
zu bieten alles was ich vorschlage ist
dass wir die veränderte Situation in der
heutigen Welt berücksichtigen müssen wir
müssen der Tatsache ins Auge sehen dass
ein großer Teil der Welt einfach nicht
mit dem einverstanden ist was die
westlichen Mächte im Moment tun sei es
in Bezug auf die Ukraine oder gegen
China dass sie nicht Teil davon sein
wollen
die westliche Gemeinschaft als solche
ist also in der Welt insgesamt zunehmend
isoliert das ist eine Tatsache
hat man sich damit in Europa überhaupt
auseinandergesetzt und sofern man sich
damit auseinandergesetzt hat wie steht
Deutschland dazu
ich stelle hier nur eine Frage sind wir
uns darüber im Klaren dass Europa
Westeuropa und die Vereinigten Staaten
sowohl zum Thema Ukraine als auch zum
Thema China
zunehmend isoliert sind
offensichtlich will Deutschland diese
Isolation nicht was tut es um aus dieser
Isolation auszubrechen würde seine
andere eine eigene Art der Beziehungen
zu den Ländern des globalen Südens
schaffen
gibt Deutschland eine andere Vorstellung
davon zu erkennen wie die Welt in
Zukunft aussehen sollte präsentierte
davon sprechen dass Deutschland
Verantwortung übernimmt dann muss es
mehr sein als die Lieferung von Leopard
Panzern an die Ukraine
das ist es was ich behaupte wo liegen
hier die anderen Verantwortungsbereiche
oder begnügt sich Deutschland schlichter
mit als großes europäisches Land als
große europäische Führungsmacht die
zweite Geige hinter den Vereinigten
Staaten zu spielen
sogar der französische Präsident hat
anderer Meinungen zu diesem Thema
vertreten er hat ja gesagt die NATO sei
Hirntod was hat macron damit gemeint das
hat er zwar lange vor dem Krieg in der
Ukraine gesagt diese Aussagen sollten
dennoch ernst genommen werden und was
hat eigentlich die NATO vor es gibt
einige Fragen die man sich auch in Bezug
auf die Vergangenheit stellen sollte ich
habe ein sehr interessantes Buch eines
jetzt in London lebenden russischen
Historikers über den Zusammenbruch der
Sowjetunion gelesen er spricht darüber
wie Gorbatschow im Grunde die deutsche
Wiedervereinigung und auch die
Mitgliedschaft des vereinigten
Deutschlands in der NATO abgesegnet habe
ohne irgendwelche Einwände ohne
irgendwelche Probleme zu sehen wie
konnte es soweit kommen dass selbst der
damalige deutsche Bundeskanzler und der
amerikanische Präsident völlig erstaunt
darüber waren dass Gorbatschow das ohne
Verhandlungen einfach so zugestanden hat
wie sind wir von dieser Art von
Großzügigkeit zum heutigen putinismus
gekommen der sich Teile der Ukraine
einverleibt wie ist diese Entwicklung zu
erklären
wird Deutschland eine Erklärung dafür
finden oder sind wir einfach
entschlossen alles über die
Vergangenheit zu vergessen und darauf zu
bestehen dass dies ein globaler Kampf
gegen die Autokratie ist und dass man
keine andere Wahl hat als sich diesem
Kampf anzuschließen
momentan gibt es keine andere Wahl aber
werden wir darüber nachdenken was falsch
gelaufen ist
was könnte in Zukunft noch schief gehen
oder sind wir auch entschlossen und dem
anzuschließen was die Vereinigten
Staaten sagen vielleicht könnte man die
Antwort relativ kurz geben also wir
haben eine
wirtschaftliche annäherungspolitik an
Russland gemacht was bis zum gewissen
gerade pazifizierend wirkt und auf der
anderen Seite haben wir eine
militärische konfrontationspolitik
weiterhin betrieben durch die Ausweitung
der NATO das von Russland aus immer als
feindlicher kriegerischer Akt empfunden
worden ist wie berechtigt auch immer und
diesen Widerspruch den haben wir nicht
lösen können weil wir versucht haben
dass beiden Seiten rechts zu machen also
von Russland als Energielieferant zu
profitieren und gleichzeitig innerhalb
der Westbindung die
weiterverschiebung der NATO Grenzen zu
akzeptieren und sie aus einer ganzen
Reihe von Gründen auch zu befürworten
das war ja quasi der Widerspruch in dem
sich die deutsche Politik in den letzten
20 Jahren bewegt und gefunden hat man
haben sie ganz viele intelligente Fragen
gestellt ne Frage ist sozusagen wie weit
geht die Westbindung was wird sein wenn
die Konfrontation zwischen China und den
in den USA eskaliert welche Rolle werden
wir dann spielen das sind alles sehr
sehr gute Fragen jetzt ist dies
natürlich auch eine Sendung wo wir uns
immer gerne bemühen ein paar Antworten
zu finden und zwar vielleicht auch
Antworten wo man sagen kann die sind
nicht nur utopisch schön sondern diese
das sind wirklich gangbare Wege hätten
sie da was praktisches vorzuschlagen wie
eine neue Weltordnung in der auf der
einen Seite wir unsere westlichen Werte
verteidigen ohne damit zu missionieren
und auf der anderen Seite eine
Weltordnung aussehen könnte in denen die
aufstrebenden Staaten zu ihrem Recht
kommen aber für den Westen keine
Bedrohung darstellen
als Schriftsteller kann ich nicht
wirklich Lösungen verordnen ich kann nur
Vorschläge unterbreiten wie wir über
dieses Thema nachdenken können
die Vorstellung dass die Weltordnung
durch festliche Interventionen oder
westliche Politik gestaltet wird ist
meiner Meinung nach vorbei
dies zu erkennen ist ein großer Schritt
nach vorne
es gibt heute viele wichtige Akteure auf
der ganzen Welt und sie werden die
Weltordnung zunehmend gestalten das
sollten wir zugeben
lassen Sie uns Ihre Rolle anerkennen
ein Beispiel china hat erst vor kurzem
ein außergewöhnliches Abkommen zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und dem Iran abgeschlossen
das zwei wichtige Führer der
muslimischen Welt zusammenbringt von
denen einer die Schiiten und der andere
die Sunniten
Interesse fast völlig unbemerkt
geblieben aber das ist ein großer
Durchbruch der China über Nacht zu einem
wichtigen Akteur im Nahen Osten macht
die Welt verändert sich also rasant vor
unseren Augen
werden wir nun unser Denken ändern das
Denken das nicht nur die Arbeit von
Ihnen und mir oder die Leitartikel in
den Zeitungen beeinflusst sondern auch
die Politikgestaltung die Arbeit all der
Akademien
jetzt wo ich in Europa lebe wird mir
klar dass ein großer Teil der Medien ein
großer Teil des Journalismus vor allem
wenn es darum geht über internationale
Beziehungen nachzudenken stark von den
Geschehnissen in Amerika beeinflusst
wird
das amerikanische Establishment
beeinflusst die öffentliche Meinung
immer noch sehr stark das politische und
militärische denken
ich glaube aber wir brauchen ein
unabhängiges Denken nicht nur darüber
welche Rolle Deutschland sondern auch
welche Rolle Europa spielen könnte und
ich meine wir müssen zuerst unser
Bewusstsein ändern bevor wir über
politische oder pragmatische Lösungen
nachdenken wir müssen unsere Analyse
erweitern
es besteht eine zu große Abhängigkeit
davon was die Vereinigten Staaten meinen
oder was sie tun könnten
wir wissen dass die Menschen in Europa
während der vier Jahre unter Trump wie
ein Hühnerhaufen herumliefen ratlos weil
sie keine Ahnung hatten wie sie sich
verhalten sollten Amerika war plötzlich
von einem verrückten übernommen worden
wir müssen also nach Quellen für neues
Denken in unseren eigenen
geschichtlichen Verläufen in unseren
eigenen Erfahrungen in den europäischen
Erfahrungen suchen und wir müssen die
unausweichliche Tatsache der
wirtschaftlichen Verpflichtung mit China
mit anderen Teilen der Welt endlich
analysieren und
Verstehens können sich die europäischen
Volkswirtschaften einen ernsthaften
Bruch in den Beziehungen zwischen dem
Westen und China und anderen Teilen des
globalen Südens überhaupt leisten ein
Entscheider Ende wenn man anfängt die
richtigen Fragen zu stellen wird sich
wie von selbst eine wohlberatene Politik
herausschälen wenn man diesen Fragen
aber weiterhin ausweicht bleiben wir in
der gleichen Sackgasse gefangen in der
wir jetzt gerade stecken
right now wenn man ihre Bücher liest
dann liest man sehr viel Kritik
imperialistischen Selbstverständnis des
Westens über seine Geschichte bis hin im
gewissen Umständen auch noch bis heute
und man liest in diesen Büchern auch
durchgängig eine ganz entscheidende
Kapitalismuskritik ja das also der vom
Westen aus der Kapitalismus quasi in die
ganze Welt hinausgedrungen ist und alles
kolonialisiert hat und im Grunde
genommen fast alle Länder der Welt zu
kapitalistischen Ländern gemacht hat in
dieser dieser neuen Weltordnung die
ihnen vorstellt dieser neuen
multipolaren Weltordnung in der der
Kompass neu gestellt wird weg von der
bipolaren Weltordnung der alten Zeit
welche Rolle spielt der Kapitalismus da
drin ich meine die aufsteigenden
aufstrebenden Länder der Welt sind
ebenfalls kapitalistische Länder zum
Teil turbo-kapitalistische Länder wie
China
glauben Sie wenn Sie jetzt einen ein
Gegenbild zu Fukuyama entwerfen ja und
sagen sozusagen der Weg zum Ende der
Geschichte wird er tatsächlich dazu
führen dass irgendwann langfristig auch
der Kapitalismus überwinden gebunden
werden muss oder würden Sie wie Fukuyama
sagen der Kapitalismus ist immer noch
besser als alles andere Moment ist die
Welt bisher versucht hat
die letzten drei Jahrzehnte stellten
eine Ausnahme dar weil wir wegen des
Zusammenbruchs der sozialistischen
alternative davon ausgegangen sind dass
der Kapitalismus der einzige Weg nach
vorne sei damit heute mit all den
Schäden am Planeten mit der
Klimakatastrophe mit dem Aufstieg
autokratischer Systeme müssen wir auf
einer ganz anderen Ebene wieder darüber
nachdenken wie wir die schlimmsten
Auswüchse des Kapitalismus abmildern
können
natürlich wird es eine Art von
Marktwirtschaft gehen es hat sie in der
Geschichte der Menschheit über sehr
lange Strecken gegeben und es wird sie
weiterhin geben aber Kapitalismus ist
eben nicht unbedingt mit Marktwirtschaft
gleichzusetzen und das ist etwas was wir
genau im Auge behalten müssen vor allem
weil wir an diesem Punkt unserer
Geschichte mit der Aussicht auf unsere
eigene Auslöschung konfrontiert sind
diese Perspektive nicht auf die Schäden
aufmerksam der reine Konsumkapitalismus
anrichtet was dann
all diese Fragen die Fukuyama und andere
1989 für erledigt hielten sind jetzt
wieder offen wie Scheunentore und ich
meine auch dass heute die besonderen
historischen Erfahrungen von Ländern die
nicht zu den Gewinnern der Geschichte
gehören immer mehr an Bedeutung gewinnen
ich danke Ihnen für das Gespräch vielen
Dank
[Musik]